time for some R&R after a long day of
scientific presentations that's why I'm
stuck Johanna Toffoli on is networking
one of her new context is a doctor from
Berlin she'd like to work in Germany but
she's also received an interesting offer
from Harvard University bright young
scientists don't have many opportunities
back in her home country Romania in my
generation I think eighty percent of
leading Karina and that's huge I mean
that's really huge and of course you can
imagine the best of them I go Johanna is
having dinner with the laureates another
tradition at the lindau conference as is
dancing the polonaise contest when the
daughter opens the floor
gentlemen and make so please all
gentlemen would be so nice if you joined
comedy
a measure of the changing times there
aren't enough men to go around that's
another surprising conclusion from
lindau time once again to think outside
the box actually a good sign for female
scientists like you're an Italian just
entering their fields and an indicator
that more Nobel Prize laureates in the
future will be women
you